هذه مشاهد ليست من فيلم سينمائيين او حرب
اهليه انها احتجاجات عمت فرنسا وخرج فيها
فرنسيون ضد مقتل المراهق للاصول الجزائريه
النائل السلطات الفرنسيه كشفت ان اعمال
الشغب خلال الاحتجاجات خلفت تدميرا نحو
الف وتسعمائه سياره كما تم ادرام النار في
حوالي 500 مبنى من بينها مراكز الشرطه
ومجالس بلديه وتم تسجيل
2560 حريقا في الطرقات العامه بباريس
وسائل الامن فرنسيه قالت ان باريس وحدها
سجلت احراق نحو الف سياره وادرام النار في
212 بنايه فيما تم تدمير 74 سياره
فيستراسبورغ السلطات الفرنسيه اعلنت القبض
على 270 شخصا خلال الليله الرابعه من
الاحتجاجات ليرتفع اجمالي الموقوفين ل
1311 وشملت اعتقالات ليله الجمعه عشرات
الاشخاص في مدينه مارسيليا الجنوبيه
واوضحت الشرطه ان الموقوفين نهبوا متجرا
للاسلحه الناريه وسرقوا بعض بنادق الصيد
لكن دون ذخيره